hi everybody i'm glenn howerton from ap
bio and i'm here with buzzfeed
to read your thirst tweets by the way
sometimes i've heard them referred to as
glirst tweets all right here we go
[Music]
i just started watching it's always
sunny and damn glenn howerton was hot in
2005
and still is i i do appreciate that and
still is
uh at the end of that because i that was
that could have gone that could have
gone horribly for me just then glenn
howerton is
sexy sexy in all caps there i said it
good they got it out of their system
i think that's important you don't want
to hold things like that inside because
it just uh
grows and festers it's good that you
said it glenn howerton's hair
gives me the strength to keep going
i love that okay cool thank genetics
for that not sure how it looks today
though glenn howerton is the king of
having a jawline
sweet it's a good feature thirsty for my
jaw i'll take it dennis reynolds is hot
i don't care
yeah i get that um basically what you're
saying is you're attracted to us
to a uh to a psychopath yeah i
understand why you would need to
qualify that and i play dennis therefore
that means you're saying i'm hot
unless it's the character in his
attitude that you find hot in which case
uh that is trouble i'm watching oh no
i'm watching that 80s show just because
glenn howerton and his hair
makes me cry yeah my hair was outrageous
on that show i'm not sure what was going
on there i feel like i wasn't
washing it it was like at a time in my
life where i didn't know what to do
it made sense for the show in my head my
only kink is glenn howerton as dennis
reynolds
well if that's your only kink that's
definitely not your only kink because
there are things that you want that you
won't admit
i've just started watching ap bio today
and i would let
jack griffin ruin my life it's
interesting when they get sort of like
violent
but i get it though i guess what you're
saying is i'm so attracted to this man
that even if
my encounter with him ruined my life it
would be worth it it's the scruff
glenn howerton could hit me with his car
and i would be like
quote thank you gorgeous man yeah listen
uh great glenn howerton show us your abs
challenge
yeah you wish why did i have three
consecutive wet dreams about glenn
howerton last night
i don't know that anybody can answer
that except uh your subconscious
don't at me but where can i get a glenn
howerton sex doll
my hope is that you can't i don't know
if i want those floating around out
there
i know there's one i don't know where
that thing is and it scares me glenn
howerton owns this
i thought i only owned one well i just
finished ap bio
and i still want a jack griffin this
person was watching a show thinking one
of these days i'm going to not want a
jack griffin and that just never
happened i want glenn howerton to cut me
open with his jawline
thank you for listening
[Laughter]
thank you for listening that's funny
anyways
would let joel mchale and glenn howerton
absolutely destroy me just
completely flatten me flatten me into a
piece of cardboard
either in character or out i'm not picky
i don't know i guess that'd be me and
joel mchale doing some
kind of like a steamroller move on you
where we we're just rolling around on
you until you're flat like a pancake
nice to know you're not picky i want
glenn howerton to choke me out you know
listen
uh i'm not into that just not into the
whole choking thing i might be missing
out though and i fully admit that i just
it scares me a little i won't do that to
you well guys uh these were your thirst
tweets
i appreciate it guys i i do it it feels
good
feels good
[Music]
you